Speaker 1: In the news lately. You've obviously
been hearing a lot about Tyree Nichols and
police brutality. If you watch the tape, the
police recordings, the body cam recordings
that have been released, you know just how
disgusting and heart wrenching the footage was.
And there's been kind of two takes in the
in the in the conservative media sphere. One
is that it was terrible what took
place. And then there's the other,
which is this wouldn't have happened if he'd only
complied. Those cops did nothing wrong. And we're
going to play a little bit of both here.
Jesse WATTERS, a parent expert on chokeholds,
oddly enough, had this to say on Fox News.
Speaker 3: Banning chokeholds, dealing with
no warrant searches, dealing with accreditation
of police departments. It's necessary that we
do all these things, but not sufficient.
Speaker 1: Typical Washington politician.
The Memphis police didn't use a single
chokehold that entire time. But Democrats
want to ban them. A chokehold done properly
with a subdued Tyree and had him handcuffed.
One, there were many cops on top of
literally on top of the £140 Tyree Nichols.
Large men of giant physical stature couldn't get
him under control. Is that what you're saying?
Jesse WATTERS And you know, or maybe you don't
because you're a dumb dumb, but you know as well
as the rest of us that Senator Durbin from
Illinois was not talking about legislation
based on this specific case. He's talking about
chokeholds and their misuse in cases all across
the country year after year after year after
year. It's not disingenuous to say there's all
of these elements in all of these cases that we
need to look at from a legislative standpoint.
And maybe that's one of the things we need to
curb. If it didn't work in this particular case
or wouldn't have affected this particular case
isn't the point. But it doesn't matter to Fox News